early on um before the league got shut
down you know the the team had brought a
doctrine um to talk to everybody you
know tell everybody okay this is this is
happening a little bit about it and one
of the first things he said was
mass do absolutely nothing
and he
he was like i'm just letting you guys
know that um
apparently the way he phrased it was
like i guess the covet particles were so
small that they could pass through you
know you know pretty much most mass
especially cloth masks
so that that was our first thing so when
he first said that i was like okay i'm
not wearing a mask and then you have
these mask mandates and things like i'm
like what is going on and so uh so yeah
it was pretty crazy in in the bubble a
lot of things didn't make sense but we
kind of just went along with it because
we wanted to play
right so all right let's talk about the
bubble situation because i think people
or people that don't pay attention to
the nba that are watching us don't even
know what that is but they basically had
you guys in your own sort of lockdown so
that the season could kind of somewhat
continue and sometimes you'd have masks
on the bench but then you take them off
to play so now you're sweating on each
other and spitting on each other and
probably bleeding on each other but then
when you sit down you're wearing this i
mean none of it really made sense did
did coaches and players talk about kind
of the craziness of the whole thing
yeah we definitely did and and i think
especially early on like when we were
first getting on getting into the bubble
everyone still the the world is so
afraid so the nba and all these
different organizations are trying to do
all that they can to kind of like okay
we need to focus on this and tackle this
but at the same time we need guys to
play so what can we do okay they wear
the mask on the bench and they go into
the game and take it off but it was it
was such hysteria and just things
weren't making sense and and so we
definitely had conversations about you
know needing to test every day and and
the mass thing you know early on um
before the leak got shut down you know
the the team had brought a doctrine um
to talk to everybody you know tell
everybody okay this is this is happening
a little bit about it and one of the
first things he said was
master do absolutely nothing and he
he was like i'm just letting you guys
know that um
apparently the way he phrased it was
like i guess the covet particles were so
small that they could pass through you
know you know pretty much most mass
especially cloth masks
so that that was our first thing so when
he first said that i was like okay i'm
not i'm not wearing a mask and then you
have these mask mandates and things like
that i'm like what is going on
and so uh so yeah it was pretty crazy in
in in the bubble a lot of things didn't
make sense but we kind of just went
along with it because we wanted to play
were you surprised the way some guys
just kind of took the orders even though
they thought it didn't work or the fact
that you guys are mostly in your mid-20s
at the peak of physical health like your
cardiovascular is better than basically
anyone on the planet you all eat right
etcetera etcetera yet everybody started
doing all this crazy stuff
i wouldn't say i was surprised i i i
mean societal pressure is is tough i
mean it it works um and especially when
you have you know people that are higher
up or um just people around you who are
who kind of adopt this mainstream you
know idea or ideology and kind of just
run with it so i i don't think i was
surprised even myself early on i was
like okay this is what we have to do it
it wasn't until things got later on and
we get out the bubble and then the
vaccine starts coming around and then i
can just see the you know just how much
it was being pushed and you have all the
people on social media you know uh
demeaning everyone and all this stuff
and then you know the thing about the
rolling stone article happens to me and
that's when i'm like okay this thing is
really not just about a vaccine it's
political there's an agenda there's a
bias to it and um but i know i wasn't
surprised that everybody kind of went
along with it all right so let's get to
that part in just a sec but i just want
to do a little more on the bubble so
again for people that don't know so they
basically had you guys
were you all pretty much in one hotel
and had to limit who was coming in and
out like they really the idea was that
you weren't going to basically see
anybody else hus you know wives kids etc
and that you would play against each
other and that was it but i've heard
from some other players that's not
exactly how the thing worked well it was
it was three hotels and so you had teams
split up in these three hotels um and
pretty much the order was like you're
not allowed to leave once you come in
that's it um as the bubble kind of went
on and we got to the playoffs i think
they allowed some people's families to
come in um or just their wives or
something like that but early on it was
like strict we test every day
i think we were testing like twice a day
i'm not even completely sure but you're
testing every day um
you know they had a lounge set up they
had a barber shop for so they tried to
kind of you know help it you know be
worthwhile but it was just it was just
tough to kind of just be in the hotel
room all the time but yeah no nothing
ain't nothing out uh food all there so
it was really like a
jail loki
i mean i heard some rumors that people
were coming and going and able to get uh
lady friends inside etc and some some
people got in trouble you know some
people who who got caught i don't i
don't know about i didn't hear anything
about guys actually being successful
with that but i i did hear the story
about one guy trying and getting in
trouble
right so okay so then the bubble passes
and now things start shifting towards
the vaccine and that's where that video
of you
uh what month do you remember what month
that was no not at all all right so it's
about a year and a half ago i mean it
was at the height of the whole thing and
basically you you gave a spectacular you
know we're we'll lay it in right here
we're going to lay in the the speech
right here so people can listen to it it
is my belief that the the vaccine status
of every person should be their own
choice um and completely up to them
without the without bullying without
being pressured without being forced
into doing so
i'm not ashamed to say that i'm
uncomfortable with taking the vaccine at
this time
i think that we're all different we all
come from different places we've all had
different experiences and hold dear to
different beliefs and uh what it is that
you do with your body when it comes to
putting medicine in there should be your
choice um free of the ridicule and the
opinion of others i've had covid um in
the past and so our understanding of
antibodies
of natural immunity has uh changed a
great deal from the onset of the
pandemic and is still evolving
um
i understand that the vaccine would um
help if you catch covet and uh you'll be
able to have less symptoms
from contracting it but with me having
covert in the past and having antibodies
with my current age group and a fitness
physical fitness level
it's not necessarily a fear of mine
taking the vaccine
like i said it would decrease my chances
of
having a severe reaction but it does
open me up to the albeit rare chance but
the possibility of having an adverse
reaction to the vaccine itself
um i don't believe that being
unvaccinated means infected or being
vaccinated means
uninfected you can still catch copit
with or we're not having the vaccine
i would say honestly the the craziness
of it all in terms of not being able to
say that it should be everybody's fair
choice without being demeaned or um
talked crazy to doesn't uh
make one comfortable to do what said
person is
telling them to do um yeah i would say
that's that's a couple of the reasons
that um you know i would say i'm
hesitant at this time but at the end of
the day
i don't feel that it is um you know
anyone's reason to come out and say well
this is why or this is not why it should
just be their decision and um
you know loving your neighbors not just
loving those that that agree with you or
look like you are
moving the same way that you do it's
it's a you know loving those who don't
so that right there i mean you laid out
more common sense decency and thoughtful
analysis than pretty much anything
i saw on cnn and that's where i was like
man i got to talk to this guy
yeah i mean so again like early on like
me just trying to take a step back and
just see everything that was going on i
was like okay they're saying that the
the virus has a 99.97 survival rate i'm
young you know people who are older and
have comorbidities or you know or obese
are really struggling with this thing so
i just said you know as i saw how much
the vaccine was being pushed and forced
on everybody and then you see you know
social media and people you know calling
people crazy for not wanting to take it
or even just being hesitant or asking
questions and then you have people's
medical and religious exemptions being
denied and people losing their jobs i
was like man this is insane this isn't
right and so i just said you know what
i'm young i'm healthy i don't have any
you know side effects or anything like
that i don't see the wisdom in putting
something into my body that's not going
to stop me from getting the virus or
transmitting it to someone else that's
just where i'm at and i'm not going to
do it and you know at the same time i
wanted to be a you know a hope and a
voice for other people who were going
through this we didn't have a platform
was that just a normal post-game press
conference were you planning on doing
that or how did that even happen were
you thinking about hey i gotta say
something no it was actually perfect
because the the rolling stone article so
so if
around that time the team calls me and
they say hey you know the rolling stone
wants to do an interview with you you
know about everything that's going on
i'm saying cool
so i get on the phone with him and he's
like you know you're unvaccinated and
i'm thinking to myself like how do you
even know that i'm a vaccinator
welcome to the mainstream media my
friend
but but yeah it was actually a great
conversation like we're talking and like
he's like oh you know what i i agree
with you on that and all that's a good
point and i pretty much laid out to him
exactly what i went on to say the next
day and and so but the article drops
that night like the sunday night and
it says jonathan isaac came to his you
know vaccination status whatever by
watching donald trump press conferences
and studying black history and that's
what i'm like oh my gosh
everybody's on social media calling me
crazy and i i sound i sound stupid in
the article
but the next day was media day so monday
is media day and i was expecting the
question i was on the phone with my
pastor that night and he was like well
you have an opportunity to talk about it
tomorrow immediately i have to ask you
about it and i just kind of tried to lay
it out there yeah so that was your first
time being hit by the media like that
huh welcome to the party well it was my
it was my first not being hit by the
media because then you have the whole
standing in the bubble thing that was
that was before that that was in june of
2020 but it was the first time right so
yeah wait let's back up tell people
about that first right we we skipped
over something big well yeah well um so
around the time of of what happened to
george floyd as as tragic and as wrong
as it was there was a lot of pressure on
nba players going into the bubble um to
have to kneel for the national anthem
and where the black lives matter t-shirt
but again
same thing with the vaccine i tried to
step back and say okay what what is the
right way for me to respond in this
moment that i feel would bring real
change um and for some people in that
moment it was kneeling and wearing the
t-shirt but for me it wasn't and so i
just looked at i looked at my life and
said you know what my life has been
supported and changed by the gospel of
jesus christ and i can't i don't see a a
greater message or a greater
antidote or hope for the times that we
see ourselves in racism and not even
that just all the things that plague the
hearts of men that i know that the
gospel can change i wanted to stand up
and give that message i didn't want to
go with anybody's narrative or you know
the whole you know as crazy as the whole
black lives matter movement was i didn't
want to you know kind of just fall into
it and so i decided to be the only one
to stand and to share that message of
you know loving your neighbor um you
know the way that you want to be loved
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell